on parle de plus en plus d'une crise de
la biodiversité un peu partout sur la
planète des espèces disparaissent à un
rythme alarmant notamment à cause de la
destruction de leur habitat mais comment
renverser cette tendance l'une des
solutions serait de relier les espaces
naturels entre eux et ainsi de réparer
une partie des erreurs du passé
[Musique]
l'aménagement du territoire et la
planification territoriale dans le passé
repos vraiment considérer beaucoup
d'ennemis naturels on essaie on avait un
projet puis on prend c'est le projet par
dessus tout naturel
depuis des années le biologiste benoît
jobin se préoccupe de l'état des milieux
naturels au québec il veut nous montrer
ce qu'il considère comme un exemple
d'aménagement désastreux pour les
écosystèmes l'autoroute dufferin
montmorency à québec
cette autoroute construite au tournant
des années 80 relie le centre-ville de
québec à l'est de la ville elle a été
construite en majeure partie dans la
battures de beauport
à l'origine ici c'était des grands
milieux humides il ya des grandes zones
inondables qui s'attirait jusqu'au bout
devant la canardière du côté du maule où
on aperçoit la canardière parce que les
à la chasse aux talents
ya eu la construction d'autoroutes si
bien que les milieux humides qui étaient
ici un qui couvrait d'être attrayante
spears y ont été coupées puisqu'on
trouve de l'autre côté de l'autoroute
france côté nord les milieux humides ont
été asséchées puis une perte énorme de
superficie de milieux humides
si aujourd'hui les projets de
développement tienne davantage compte de
l'impact sur l'environnement benoît
jobin s'inquiète que les plans
d'aménagement territoriaux peine encore
à tailler une juste place au milieu
naturel
le biologiste et co auteur de l'atlas
des territoires d'intérêt pour la
conservation dans les basses terres du
saint laurent
de nombreuses données et cartographie y
sont colligées ce qui permet une vision
globale de l'utilisation du territoire
et surtout l'identification des endroits
où un effort de conservation est
nécessaire voire urgent
quand on descend à moins de 30% de
couverts de milieux naturels dans un
territoire donné on va perdre des
espèces on va perdre des fonctions
écologiques que les écossais vont
procurer à la fois on à la flore à la
société
si toutes les régions urbaines souffrent
d'un manque de milieux naturels
au québec la région la plus touchée si
la montérégie
dans cette mer de terres agricoles et de
ville qui s'étalent à perte de vue le
pourcentage de couverts naturel et bien
en-deça du 30% souhaitable
de milieux forestiers une grosse perte
de milieux humides aussi puis aussi la
conversion des titres de culture on est
passé d'une culture de fourrage de
pâturage vers des cultures de maïs
soyaux dépôt des milieux sont très peu
propices à la biodiversité donc en une
perte de milieu mais on est aussi une
perte de qualité de la diminuer au vert
si bien qu'aujourd'hui on s'en rend
compte que les milieux naturels sont
résiduelles ils sont très très
fragmentés dans le paysage
on peut pas perdre d'autres milieux
naturels parce que c'est le sud ouest du
québec c'est là qu'on retrouve le plus
d'espèces labiodh verser la plus grande
dans le sud du québec
devant ce constat plusieurs projets
voient le jour pour établir des lieux de
conservation et de la biodiversité dans
le paysage
[Musique]
depuis plusieurs années charles lucie
travaille avec des agriculteurs à
implanter ce que l'on appelle des
corridors de biodiversité
il s'agit des trois corridors où l'on
plante des arbres afin de relier deux
espaces fréquentés par la fondent la
place de la vieille favoriser des
habitats pour la faune notamment pour
les oiseaux bien des corridors de
déplacement pour les oiseaux mais aussi
pour la forme comme renault
les et deviennent des habitats entrons
pour les coccinelles coccinelle maculé
coccinelles asiatiques qui sont des
grands prédateurs sur les ravageurs donc
c'est un bénéfice pour le produit
agricole ça donne un très beau coup
d'oeil quand tu te lèves le matin tu
regardes ça ça fait très beau le soir
vous coucher de soleil c'est superbe
c'est sûr que là aujourd'hui on est là
on sent qu'il ya peu de vent il y aurait
pas ça c'est sûr qu'on aurait je veux
dans la
salle ça coupe le vent c'est sûr que tu
le bélier dany
à clarenceville tout près de la
frontière américaine charles lussier
travaille aussi sur cette terre achetés
par le gouvernement du québec
s'est unitaire de 100 ans qui a été
acheté pour la conservation avant tout
et autour de la terre on a vraiment un
paysage typique de la montérégie dont
grandes cultures maïs soya parsemé de
boisés
et donc on vient ici créer un nouveau
boisé
il procède ici à un reboisement de
chaînes bi colore
sommes au taux de la baie missisquoi
dans des terres très basse c'est son
habitat idéal et d'ailleurs on le
retrouve ici à 200 m une colonie nous
vient prolonger c'était colonies là donc
on vient ici en étudiant les friches
reconstruit des anciennes forêts
patrimoniale
l'achat de terres pour faire de la
conservation est une tendance qui
s'implante de plus en plus aux pays
comme en montérégie
divers organismes offrent à dix
propriétaires privés de vendre une
parcelle de leur terrain pour soi
développer une zone de conservation ou
bien de favoriser des activités
agricoles en lien avec la conservation
un bon exemple se déroule dans
l'archipel du lac saint pierre
chaque année l'agriculteur richard
plante par de saint-ignace-de-loyola
avec tout son équipement
ils traversent le fleuve pour atteindre
l'île de grâce
ça faisait 12 un cas plus d'agriculteurs
sur des grosses
chef de la branche puis on a labouré
dans bright food on aura mené des
attaques et qui était en train de sperme
il fait aujourd'hui les foins après
plusieurs autres tentatives
infructueuses
ça n'est
pas donné ben quoi parce que beaucoup
mangé par les chevreuils des
richard plante est locataire ici depuis
1996 l'organisme conservation de la
nature est propriétaire des lieux elle
loue ainsi la terre à l'agriculteur pour
ses soins mais aussi pour qu'ils
entretiennent les lieux afin de
favoriser la biodiversité
l'agriculture est souvent mis en
opposition avec la conservation et c'est
pas nécessairement d'accord on pense
souvent que la conservation et une
approche très ferme très strict où on
vieillit sortir les usages de la zone
conserver c'est pas comme ça qu'on fait
de la conservation
d'être en fourrage comme ça et faire les
foins c'est compatible avec l'endroit où
on se trouve c'est compatible avec les
missions de conservation
l'agriculture ici elle nous permet entre
autres de garder comme on le voit le
milieu ouvert donc a pas de réformer
station qui va se faire les milieux
ouverts avec des rangées d'arbres vous
permettre certaines espèces d'oiseaux
champêtre des espèces qu'on cible c'est
à dire qu'on va permettre aux oiseaux
d'humidifier
de lui des prix est en voie de
disparition on est déçu mais a remonté
les populations ça lieu plein de points
ça dépend des prêts et des deux points à
ses godillots mais il ne va pas et c'est
là qu'on arrive les onze ans mais
aujourd'hui on envoie le plusieurs des
découpes de vote des prix c'est une
fierté
de participer sow
même si tous ces gestes individuels de
conservation ont un impact positif sur
l'environnement pour le biologiste
benoît jobin il est grand temps d'avoir
une vision d'ensemble une véritable
prise de conscience et surtout un
changement de culture dans la
planification du territoire
les actions de conservation des
acquisitions de terrains où il ya une
valeur de conservation élevé on a en
fait depuis 20 ans depuis 30 ans qui on
se rend compte que c'est pas suffisant
pour ralentir le déclin des populations
de 300 p r si on laisse les choses aller
comme on le fait depuis depuis des
décennies et des décennies on va se
retrouver avec des menus qui sont
tellement perturbé des minutes sont
tellement détruit que on va voir on va
avoir des crises des crises écologiques
comme on oublie qu'avec les grandes
inondations avec lille charlotte et les
gens à vivre
il en est rendue je pense à la croisée
des chemins où faut que les milieux
naturels soient considérés comme des
atouts la planification territoriale
c'est plus pour pouvoir les milieux
naturels comme étant une contrainte pour
développement mais faut plutôt les voir
comme étant un atout parce que ces
milieux apporte des services écologiques
et des liens à la société
[Musique]
tous